If you're in school, here are some
witchy tips for you.
>> Witch Talk, the witchcraft videos with
billions of views.
>> And I remember just seeing this girl who
was like, "So, here's my crystals and
here's like my my tarot cards." And they
made it look like it was like this just
like this cutesy thing that we're just
going to do, you know? And I was like,
"But that's witchcraft." And [music]
like back in the heyday, like the Salem
witch trials, like people were not
having it, you know? Donald Trump,
Putin, Charlie Kirk, people really find
controversial, may may or may not like.
There are evidence that people actually
are putting spells on all of these
people as well. This is from Wired. It
says Tik Tok has become [music] the home
of modern witchcraft. The fastest
growing religion among young people in
America is wikah and witchcraft.
>> And I was just in the UK um and while I
was in Canada earlier this summer, this
thing is huge. One of the pastors in in
London told me this a few years back
that for every Christian pastor in
London there are 30 witches.
>> Oh wow.
>> And all weekend these witches pray for
the destruction of Christian churches.
>> And he said one of the maybe he you know
he he couldn't make a a matter of fact
statement. He said but possibly one of
the evidences of this is that the
churches in England are becoming pubs
>> and mosques rather than churches
anymore.
>> That in fact this is happening. One of
the interesting things and there's a you
know um even men like uh Donald Trump,
Putin, Charlie Kirk, people who people
really find controversial may may or may
not like they there are evidence that
people actually are putting spells on
all of these people as well. There was
an article on a website called Jezebel
where um and this was back it was
published September 8th but uh they they
paid this editor whoever did this on on
Jezebel they paid a couple of Etsy
witches
>> oh my
>> to have a curse on Charlie Kirk.
>> Wow.
>> Uh and so if you go back um I think they
actually like paid the Etsy witches like
uh August 24 and the Etsy witches said
oh it'll take a couple weeks two three
weeks for this to take effect. And uh if
you scroll down like in the article um
one of the like witches was like burning
a photo of Charlie Kirk is like one of
the things that they did. And so part of
me wonders like how does that fit? How
does the spiritualism aspect of it fit
when you have somebody trying to curse
somebody else in today's society?
>> Well, they if they can put spells on
them, they can put spells on anyone.
Yeah.
>> Right. And so there is a new world where
these things are unveiled. And we'll
talk more about them in some other
sessions. But these things are being
unveiled and released onto society where
spiritualism. So So let me look at a
couple have a couple more of these witch
talk the witchcraft videos with billions
of views.
>> Billions
>> billions of views. And it's called witch
talk, not Tik Tok. It's inside Tik Tok.
Wow. So they call it Witch Talk. And so
here's one. Mitch. The rise of the
occult on social media has eerie
parallels with the 16th century.
>> I remember a while ago I was working on
some kind of a video. I don't even
remember what topic it was on. It was an
Live show and I was looking for some
videos on on Wishcraft and social media
and I remember just seeing this girl who
was like, "Yeah, and so here's my
crystals and here's like my my tarot
cards." And they made it look like it
was like it's just like this cutesy
thing that we're just going to do, you
know? And I was like, "But that's
witchcraft." like back in the heyday
like pe the Salem witch trials like
people were not having it you know not
saying we should do that now but what
I'm saying is that the mindset of people
has completely shifted it's popular now
to become witches like you said because
of Tik Tok break
>> you might experience something similar
this year hearing those familiar words
>> trickor treat
>> but instead of giving them a trick or a
treat give them truth
Get our new sharing cards on [music]
spiritualism and witchcraft and give
them something better.
[music]
One of the things that fueled this
during the um co and the shutdown was
people felt powerless and they say that
as they were home digging around on the
internet and this stuff's just like
prevalent all over the place. It was
like offering you power for, you know,
like something where like now I can
control this. And that's really what
it's about. It's like I want to control
the elements. I want to control the
things. And I mean, it's really taking
the miracles and the position that God
has for us away from God and going, I'm
going to put it in my own hands.
>> Yep.
>> Well, we got it. It's been served to
society. Um, and you know, we did a one
on just spiritualism. It starts with
shows like Bewitched.
>> Yeah. I was listening to CD Brooks
preaching from like the 70s and he
brought that up. He's like Bewitched and
The Ghosts Next Door something and he
was naming some of these TV shows that
seemed relatively
watch so you know and and Scooby-Doo
changed at first. It was always a hoax
>> the first few seasons then it was real
real ghosts and real stuff by the end of
the of the of the show or by the
reiteration of the show. So it was
served in but that just exposed you to
it gave you interest in it. What social
media has done is found a way to make
you participate in it.
>> Oh yeah.
>> Yeah. I remember I grew up on Harry
Potter like I was younger and Harry
Potter came out [music] for the first
time. Um and then after watching the
movies we started going to the library
and reading the books and then we got
the video games. And now I was doing it
in the video games and in my mind I
wanted to be like Harry Potter. I was
actually saying out loud these spells
that I was supposed to do in the video
games because it becomes real, you know.
And the same thing here now they're
teaching you how to actually do it. So
it's one step further, which back then,
yeah, you did it in a video game and it
made me do it [music] technically like
just say the spells, but now it's like
no, we're actually going to teach you
how you can do it. [music]
>> [music]
[music]